six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go next
to our caller from the eight five six
area code eight five six go ahead and
introduce yourself who's this hi Dave
this is Jensen calling hey I am from
Cherry Hill New Jersey I had a question
Trump has denied pretty much everything
that is real news as fake news so let's
say in 2020 Bernie Sanders or Joe Biden
beats him into electoral college okay
what would you see a scenario where he
dismisses the election as a a state news
and refuses to give up you know we've
gotten similar questions in the past
when Obama was president the right
started talking about how he was going
to suspend the the 2016 election and
declare himself president indefinitely
sorry what was it but Obama was
reasonable well but regardless of that
there was no evidence that that's
something Obama was going to do so until
we actually hear something from Trump
look I get what you're saying Trump is
so unreasonable that we could say he
would be liable to just deny the
election results in 2020 if he loses and
say I'm still president he wouldn't be
allowed to do it like ultimately he
would just be removed unless he
convinced the entire diplomatic state
and and military apparatus that he was
robbed in some way and the results were
wrong he would just be he would be asked
to leave he would just be escorted out
eventually so no unless we have a recent
as progressives until and if we have a
real reason to think that Trump would do
that I wouldn't consider it a realistic
possibility okay all right I hope you're
right about this thanks Dave all right
no problem
great to hear from you thanks for the
call